WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE HAVE STUNNING NEW DUDE
DETAILS FOR YOU ON THAT
HORRIFYING NURSING MOMENT ATTACK
IN DETROIT THAT WE SHOWED YOU ON
FRIDAY NIGHT.
THE STORY IS EVEN WORSE THAN
REALIZED.
IT TURNS OUT AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
FROM GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMORE
MAY HAVE PLAYED A ROLE IN WHAT
YOU SAW.
FIRST OF ALL, HAPPY MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND.
IT’S POSSIBLE YOU MAY HAVE SPENT
MONTHS TRAPPED INDOORS PER
GOVERNMENT ORDERS.
IT’S ESSENTIAL THAT ALL OF IT IS
NEEDED AND THAT NATURE’S
MEDICINE.
HAPPY BALANCED PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT INTUITIVELY.
IT’S TOO LATE FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE AT CNN.
THEY HAVEN’T EVEN BEEN TRAPPED
INSIDE FOR MONTHS.
FOR REASONS THAT NO ONE HAS EVER
REALLY EXPLAINED, CABLE NEWS THE
OPERATORS HAVE BEEN CLASSIFIED
AS ESSENTIAL WORKERS FROM THE
VERY FIRST DAY.
THEY DIDN’T LOSE THEIR JOBS, AND
IF ANYTHING THEY ARE THRIVING IN
THE MIDST OF THIS DISASTER.
THEY FEEL MORE ESSENTIAL THAN
THEY EVER HAVE AND WERE
SUFFERING HAS BEEN THE BEST
THING TO THAT HAS HAPPENED TO
THEM SINCE IMPEACHMENT.
WHEN THEY GOT TO SPEND A FULL
MONTH PRETENDING TO KNOW WHERE
UKRAINE WAS.
SO THE FACT THAT YOU DISOBEYED
THEM DRIVE THEM INSANE.
HERE’S CNN.
>> THESE ARE NOT THE IMAGES THAT
HEALTH OFFICIALS WERE HOPING TO
SEE THIS MEMORIAL DAY, DAY,
PARTYGOERS IGNORING SOCIAL
DISTANCING RULES AND PACKED THIS
POOL IN MISSOURI OVER THE
WEEKEND.
>> BEACHES, BOARDWALKS AND POOLS
PACKED WITH MANY PEOPLE ARE NOT
WEARING MASKS AND NOT SOCIALLY
DISTANCING.
EVEN HEALTH EXPERTS WARNED THAT
IF THEY DON’T SOCIAL DISTANCE
THERE WILL BE A SPIKE IN
CORONAVIRUS CASES WITHIN THE
NEXT TWO WEEKS.
BUT THE QUESTION ABOUT MASKS,
TAKE A LOOK.
THERE ISN’T A SINGLE PERSON ON
THIS BEACH WEARING ONE.
>> CROWDED VACATIONERS ON THE
BOARDWALK IN OCEAN CITY,
MARYLAND, AND AT MYRTLE BEACH,
SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> EVEN AS STATES START TO
REOPEN, I DON’T EVEN LIKE THE
TERM REOPENING BECAUSE IT
SYMBOLIZES THE FLOODGATES BEING
OPENED.
>> THIS BEING CNN, A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON’T ACTUALLY HEAR ANY
OF THAT.
AND THAT’S WHERE THE NETWORK
TRACKS THE BULK OF HIS AUDIENCE.
PRODUCERS THOUGHT OF THAT
THOUGH, THEY MADE SURE TO
REINFORCE THEIR MESSAGE WITH
GRAPHICS ON THE SCREEN.
CROWDS ACROSS THE U.S. IGNORED
GUIDELINES, SPEARING FEARS HAVE
SPREAD IT.
MEMORIAL DAY CROWDS SPARKED THE
FEAR OF NEW OUTBREAKS.
THE DEATH TOLL NEARS 100,000.
YOU SHOULD BE TERRIFIED SO NO
EXPLANATION WAS NECESSARY.
OVER ON MSNBC, THE USUAL RETIRED
COLLECTION OF CIA ANALYST WAS
TERRIFIED.
THEY FEAR THAT SOMEWHERE OUT
THERE IN AMERICA THERE MIGHT
STILL BE PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN
MORE THAN SHOPPING IN VACATIONS.
HORRIFYING.
IT’S POSSIBLE THEY FETTER THAT
PEOPLE LIKE THIS, DANGEROUS
RELIGIOUS EXTREMISTS MIGHT
SOMEHOW FIND EACH OTHER AND COME
TOGETHER AND PRAY.
BUT PLAY TO SOMETHING CALLED GOD
AND THAT CANNOT BE ALLOWED.
>> OF THE VIRUS IS NOT
RELIGIOUS, IT WON’T RESPOND TO
PRAYER I’M AFRAID.
HE LOVES CONGREGATIONS.
>> AGGRESSIVE DEFIANCE IN SOME
INSTANCES, AND THEY HAVE
SIMILARLY HATCHED THEIR FORTUNE
TO SCIENCE AND DATA.
>> REGARDLESS OF HOW THAT PLAYS
OUT TO CHURCH AND STATE, AND
THAT’S WHAT PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS CONTINUE TO ADVISE THAT
THIS IS NOT A TIME TO BECOME
COMPLACENT.
>> Tucker: THERE YOU HAVE IT,
JEB BUSH’S DIMWITTED SPOKESWOMAN
IS NOW REBRANDED AS AN EMINENT
EPIDEMIOLOGIST, AND THAT PUTS
THOSE LOCKDOWN ORDERS IN PLACE
BASED ON "SCIENCE AND DATA.
OKAY, WE WILL TAKE THE
CHALLENGE.
WHAT SCIENCE AND DATA ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT EXACTLY.
WE WILL WAIT AS WE RIFLE THROUGH
YOUR PAPERS AND ABSTRACTS, WHICH
COULD TAKE A WHILE BECAUSE IN
FACT THERE IS STILL NO SCIENCE
OR DATA AT ALL, AFTER TWO MONTHS
OF THOSE LOCKDOWN’S.
SORRY, BUT STATES THAT LOCKDOWN
EARLY AND AGGRESSIVELY ARE NO
BETTER OFF TODAY ON AVERAGE.
THERE IS SCIENCE AND DATA THAT
GOING OUTSIDE IS VITAL TO YOUR
HEALTH AND HAS BEEN FOR 100
YEARS.
THIS MAKES YOU HEALTHIER AND
LESS VULNERABLE TO CORONAVIRUS.
THE VIRUS ALSO SPREADS FAR LESS
EASY EASILY OUTDOORS THAN A
DOZEN DOORS.
IN FACT IT’S THE LARGEST STUDY
OF THE SUBJECT EVER DONE, TOOK A
LOOK AT 318 CORONAVIRUS.
THEY FOUND THAT 317 OUT OF 318
CLUSTERS AND 99.7%, THE
INFECTION SPREAD INDOORS.
NOT OUTDOORS, INDOORS.
AND INDOORS IS WHERE SCIENCE AND
DATA IN DR. MSNBC REMARKED ON MY
CONSISTS YOU MUST REMAIN.
SO, THEY ARE PEDDLING PANIC AND
RECKLESS MORAL JUDGMENT AND IT’S
HAVING AN AWFUL EFFECT ON THE
COUNTRY.
AND HERE, ONE WOMAN ATTACKS
OTHER CUSTOMERS WERE NOT WEARING
A MASK.
>> GET OUT!
>> [BLEEP] >> GET OUT.
>> Tucker: YOU HATE TO SEE
AMERICANS TREATING EACH OTHER
LIKE THAT.
BUT MULTIPLY WHAT YOU JUST SAW
BY ANOTHER COUNTRY YOU GET A
SENSE OF WHAT A RELENTLESS FLOW
OF LIVES.
IT’S A NEW SURVEY BY THE CENSUS
BUREAU THAT FOUND THAT MORE THAN
ONE-THIRD OF ALL AMERICANS NOW
SHOW SIGNS OF ANXIETY,
DEPRESSION OR BOTH.
YOU WOULD THINK THE MOST FEARFUL
PEOPLE WOULD BE THE ONES MOST AT
RISK AND THAT’S PEOPLE OVER 80.
BUT JUST THE OPPOSITE TURNED OUT
TO BE TRUE.
YOUNGER PEOPLE ARE MORE
MISERABLE.
THE YOUNGER, THE MORE MISERABLE.
THE MOST MISERABLE GROUP OF ALL
OUR AMERICANS UNDER 30 AND THAT
GROUP IF YOU LOOK AT SCIENCE AND
DATA FACE VIRTUALLY NO RISK OF
DYING FROM THE VIRUS.
NONE.
THE PEOPLE ON TELEVISION HAVE
LIED TO THEM AND IT’S WORKING
THEIR LIVES.
MEANWHILE THE PEOPLE ON
TELEVISION THEMSELVES ARE JUST
FINE, THEY DON’T SEEM AFRAID.
ANDREW CUOMO’S BROTHER WORKED AT
CNN AND HE HAD THE VIRUS A WHILE
BACK.
DIDN’T BOTHER TO QUARANTINE WHEN
HE HAD IT.
HE DROVE TO HIS SECOND HOME AND
WANDERED AROUND WITH NO MASK ON.
IN MICHIGAN OVER THE PAST
WEEKEND,
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMER’S
HUSBAND DECIDED TO VIOLATE HIS
OWN WIFE’S ORDERS BY TRAVELING
ACROSS THE STATE TO USE HIS BOAT
BOAT.
HEY, IT’S MEMORIAL DAY.
WHEN THE MARINA TOLD HIM THEY
COULD NOT PUT BOAT IN THE WATER,
HE LET THEM KNOW THAT HIS WIFE
WAS GOVERNOR.
HE GOT CAUGHT OF COURSE.
AND WHEN CONFRONTED AT FIRST,
GOVERNOR WHITMER TRIED TO CLAIM
IT NEVER WOULD HAVE BEEN.
SHE DISMISSED THE WHOLE THING AS
AN INTERNET HOAX.
NOW SHE SAYING IT WAS ALL SOME
KIND OF JOKE.
IF THEY THINK UP THEIR OWN
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR YOU, AND YOU
WANT TO KNOW WHAT ALL THE
HUFFING AND PUFFING AND
MORALIZING AND JUDGING YOU
ISRAEL, WATCH THIS CLIP.
IT’S FROM MSNBC.
>> ARE THE PEOPLE THEY ARE JUST
NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT?
ARE THEY NOT WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
OWN PERSONAL SAFETY?
>> NOBODY IS WEARING THEM,
INCLUDING THE GOVERNMENT.
>> STRIKING IMAGES.
>> Tucker: BUSTED.
BUSTED.
TURNS AROUND TO HASSLE SOME GUY
IN A PACKARD JERSEY.
LOOK AT THAT GUY, HE’S NOT
WEARING A MASK.
THE GUY IN THE PACKERS JERSEY
CALLS HIM OUT AND SAYS THAT THAT